et bien tenez-vous bien cette invention
n'a pas encore de nom contrairement au
sandwich popularisé par l'ordre sandwich
le sandwich c'est un peu comme la
confiture ça dégouline souvent en
inventeur gersoie ses penché sur cette
graphe question de la cohabitation entre
le contenant et le contenu la baguette
et la garniture résultat une barquette
ingénieuse qui vient d'être primée au
concours Lépine à Paris Olivier Stephan
Serge Liberge
Christian Lafargue s'est penché sur un
grave problème qui nous concerne tous
le sandwich il a inventé le principe
d'une barquette que l'on achètera toute
prête toute variété possible sanglier
pistache au jambon beurre sans couler ni
salissures sans plan de travail
nécessaire en sécurité sans couteau qui
conserve le croustillant du pain on
déchire l'enveloppe hygiénique on glisse
la barquette
on retire la languette de la barquette
on enlève la barquette
c'est prêt
et rien que pour la caméra on prend un
couteau pour vérifier que ça marche bien
de ces barquettes rien qu'en France on
s'en rendra des centaines de millions
par an et bien tenez-vous bien cette
invention n'a pas encore de nom
contrairement au sandwich popularisé par
l'ordre
sandwichs
c'est de la modestie pas du tout je
pense qu'il y a certainement un nom à
trouver beaucoup plus évocateur que
maintenant personnel fini les travaux
pratiques à la lotte sandwich que grâce
lui soit vendu un concours définira
bientôt le nom de ces barquettes afin
qu'en masse et nous soit vendus et
bientôt vous aussi vous posséderez le
dernier gadget absolu des repas rapides
[Musique]